so as we pick up with age of Ultron
issue number five there are a couple
things we need to clarify the reason why
is because this story is going to become
relatively confusing in a very fast pace
now the whole basis for this age of
Ultron story is that the Ultron force is
oh I guess these various Ultron robots
have successfully conquered the planet
Earth and at the beginning of this story
we didn't know how all we had really
known is that they had simply just
appeared and began destroying various
cities it wasn't until the last issue or
I guess until issues number three and
four that we learned that what appeared
to be the case was that the vision was
maybe controlling these robots but what
the vision had informed us was that
Ultron in the future was controlling
these robots and so what had basically
taken place is that Ultron had used the
vision as a conduit and what this means
is that the vision is more or less an
open window from the future into the
present and so what Ultron did is by
virtue of manipulating the vision he
created this window he established this
window that allowed him to speak from
the future into his past which is the
current timeline or the current set of
circumstances in the Marvel or in this
comic but what we see as the story
begins to open up here is that the
superheroes are making their way to Nick
Fury's bunker and Tony begins to more or
less comment on this Tony Stark begins
to I guess comment on their current
situation and saying that this is all
funny to him in a very dark and humorous
kind of way and the reason why was
because when the vision had first showed
up the vision was an agent of Ultron and
so they didn't really know if they could
trust the vision or not but the vision
had turned against Ultron and helped the
Avengers defeat Ultron and so because of
this the Avengers simply just welcomed
the vision in the skull at which
eventually married the vision they had
befriended the vision and while they had
treated the vision like a human the fact
remained that the vision was not the
vision was a robot and so they didn't
understand the technology that was used
by Ultron to create the vision they
really had no understanding of the
vision and so it could very well be that
there was a subroutine implanted in the
vision somewhere along the
line that would allow Ultron to alter
his programming or to take control of
the vision that would allow the vision
to become a conduit for Ultron to
manipulate the past from the future but
again Tony Stark's more or less just
talking to himself here he's more or
less just providing this commentary for
himself and the reason why is because a
lot of the other superheroes are more or
less assuming that Tony Stark has kind
of lost his mind and so we see that
Captain America is doing what he can to
keep everybody's morale up to keep
everybody focused on the current
objective which is to reach Nick Fury's
bunker from here we see that they are
they arrived at the bunker they're
currently at its location but again
they're very wary here and the reason
why they're so wary is because they
don't know what's on the other side they
don't know what's within the bunker it
could very well be that Ultron was aware
of this bunker because he was in the
future and he had planted a multitude of
Ultron robots inside and that once the
door is opened these robots would come
pouring out and annihilate all of these
superheroes and so he initially calls on
Emma Frost but emma says that the basis
or I guess the the fortitude of this
compound is such that she can't access
it using her telepathy she doesn't know
what's within this this bunker he then
calls on Wolverine and Wolverine says it
to him it just smells like a jungle
again commenting that he doesn't know
what's on the other side but what Emma
Frost says is that she doesn't like this
that if the bunker was built to keep
telepaths out then that means that it
could be that on again on the other side
of this bunker our Ultron robots we then
see that that Captain America calls on
on Susan storm and asks Susan storm if
she can use her invisibility to get
closer to the entrance without being
detected and when she does she realizes
two things that one there's some kind of
a Quixote code here there's some kind of
a keypad that has to be used to access
this giant door but the other thing is
that this door doesn't necessarily seem
to be something that can easily be
destroyed that none of the superheroes
as it appears would be able to tear this
door down now initially Captain America
calls on spider-man here and asked
spider-man if he senses any kind of a
danger but spider-man says it is
our doesn't work that way that his
spider sense is reactionary that he
himself has to be in danger in order for
him to actually order for his spider
sense to actually go off and so he uses
the only option left to him which is
Thunderbolt Ross the Red Hulk and so
what the Red Hook does is used his vast
strength his incredible strength to
punch down the door which of course we
had previously believed was something
that just couldn't be done but what we
see almost immediately after he enters
in the other superheroes begin to make
their way in is that he is pelted by a
barrage of bullets and the bullets
appear to be the kind that may not
necessarily kill Thunderbolt Ross but at
the very least are possibly able to
injure him and what we learn is that the
person that shooting Thunderbolt Ross
with all these bullets is in fact Nick
Fury himself telling us that Nick Fury
has yet again managed to find a way to
survive against all odds because despite
the fact that Nick Fury is an
established SHIELD agent that's by the
fact that he is the director of shield
in the end Nick Fury is just a man that
he can be killed just like anybody else
and that the Infinity formula as we had
previously talked about our Nick Fury
videos only goes as far as enabling to
him enabling him to survive the I guess
the aspect of dying of old age and so
what Nick Fury says here is that before
any of them enter the bunker that he's
going to use some kind of scanning
device to make sure that they are in
fact who they claim to be that they're
not ultra on robots disguised as humans
and so once he's satisfied with this
once he realizes that all of them are in
fact who they claim to be he allows them
into the bunker and from what from this
point when Nick Fury tells us is that
he's been here for about a week or so
that he's surprised that it took these
superheroes to get here this long but
they say that they didn't even know this
bunker was here they were totally
unaware of it that it wasn't until till
black Black Widow and March Spectre had
arrived that they had learned that this
bunker was actually in existence and
what Nick Fury says is that he had built
this bunker after the scroll invasion
after the secret invasion now the secret
invasion is again a story we haven't
gotten into yet this was a story that
had taken place after Civil War but the
secret invasion was a story whereby the
scrolls were invading the planet Earth
and replicating various superheroes and
humans and so Nick Fury knowing that he
couldn't really trust anybody had
designed this bunker so that if things
went from bad to worse or some extreme
measure had to be taken that he would be
able to do that and this extreme measure
is actually revealed to us by by Tony
Stark what we learn is that this bunker
is not just a bunker that this bunker is
more or less doctor dooms time platform
now again doctor dooms time platform is
not something that we've talked about
yet because we haven't really gotten
into Doctor Doom but the time platform
is exactly what it sounds like it allows
individuals to travel through time and
so again this is we're going to be
seeing these superheroes manipulate the
concept of time what Nick Fury also says
is that he believes that Ultron is in
the future which is something that we
were already aware of but what he says
is that the idea here the entire basis
of this plan was something that wasn't
necessarily contingent on the
superheroes that he was going to give
them a few more days but that if they
didn't show up that he was going to go
on its assignment by himself and so we
see that for the most part various
superheroes begin to chime in and begin
to volunteer themselves of course March
Spectre Moon Knight volunteers along
with Black Widow but we see the Nick
Fury's telling them that he's going to
need more than two of them now the plan
is to go directly to where Ultron is at
two interests fortress and to
effectively just annihilate him but it's
not going to be something that can be
done with sheer force that it's going to
require both a lot of stealth and a lot
of firepower and then he has a lot of
technology to go with it the Tony Stark
is against this Tony Stark rationalizes
that if Ultron is in the future then
this current moment is Ultron's past and
so if this is Ultron is passed then
Ultron knows what's going to happen here
he knows what road they're going to take
and so he knows that they're going to
attempt to arrive at his fortress and
they're going to attempt to destroy him
and so he's going to be prepared for it
but Quicksilver chimes in and says that
it's their only real hope it's the only
real opportunity they have but then
Wolverine chimes in and Wolverine says
this is not necessarily the case
Wolverine rationalizes here that Hank
Pym was the one who created Ultron and
that they could go back in time if they
wanted to
and they could kill Hank Penn before he
ever created Ultron now initially this
idea is almost immediately turned down
by everyone everyone says that this
can't be done that if they went back and
killed Hank Pym before you made Ultron
that they would be killing him for
something that he hadn't done yet they'd
be killing an innocent man but not only
that they'd be killing a friend
and so the ramifications of this are
something that they can't even begin to
understand that if Hank Pym doesn't
exist what would the future look like
what could possibly happen things could
turn out almost exactly the way they are
now or they could turn out far darker
than they currently are or they could
turn out much better than they are the
fact remains no one knows what would
happen to the entire space-time
continuum if this action took place and
so this idea of Wolverines is almost
immediately shot down this is almost not
going to happen no one is really on the
side of this and so what Nick Fury does
is that he says that while everybody
else is trying to figure out what they
want to do he unlocks this kind of vault
this more or less weapons cache and when
he does we see a multitude of arms and
armament belonging to various either
dead or alive superheroes that may have
handed their stuff over to Nick Fury of
course we see Magneto's helmet we see
the mark - from from Iron Man's past
which of course was a very primitive
Iron Man armor and is one that's not
tapped into any kind of network and so
Ultron wouldn't be able to take over
this suit we see of course various
things like Hawkeye Zaros and so on and
so forth but what's explained to us here
is that all these things are going to
need to be used all these things are
going to have to be used for the purpose
of invading Ultron's Ultron's fortress
but again we see that most of these
superheroes are a little hesitant here
most of these superheroes while they are
very interested in defeating Ultron at
the very least have these very subtle
unsure I guess motives or feelings
they're a little nervous about what's
going to take place but none of them are
really backing out and so once they
realize where the coordinates are going
to be once they realize where it is
they're going to arrive and what it is
that they're going to do most all the
superheroes on board and so what we see
is that as a time platform begins to
activate Quicksilver says that if they
don't make it back I'm sorry I make sure
you says it they don't make
get back that they're supposed to burn
this place down they're supposed to
destroy the entire bunker and so we see
the superheroes begin to I guess travel
into the future by virtue of this
platform but almost immediately after
most of the superheroes jump into the
future we see that Wolverine asks Peter
Parker if he knows how to manipulate
this time platform then Peter Parker
says they asked him if whether or not he
wants to chase after him
but what Wolverine says is that he wants
to go back into the past that he wants
to go back and he wants to kill Hank Pym
Peter Parker is almost immediately
against this but Wolverine says that in
a very interesting kind of a situation
here that there really is no hope for
the forces of Nick Fury that the Ultron
forces had killed for they had killed
the thing they'd killed Luke Cage they
killed some of the strongest superheroes
and so for those superheroes to attempt
to go back for Red Hook to go back along
with others that there really wouldn't
be anything they could do to stop the
forces of Ultron so the only real option
here is for them to go back into the
past and for them to kill Hank Pym at
this point we're going to go ahead and
bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it if you did let me know
and I will catch you guys later peace
you